wir kennen die friends etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich habe
lange überlegt okay was kann man
vielleicht auch mal wieder neues machen
ich musste eigentlich hatte diese idee
auch schon ein bisschen länger habe es
allerdings irgendwie nie geschafft da
jetzt mal intensiv zeit reinzustecken
bevor wir nicht starten kann ich direkt
sagen es wird glaube ich echt
interessant und am ende gibt es eine
kasse wenden deswegen bleibt dran das
sage ich sonst nie aber heute deutlich
dass wir das zu sagen ich hab im letzten
jahr viel mit online-shopping gemacht
ich habe sowieso immer viele sachen die
irgendwie internet zu tun haben und ich
habe auch von ultra auf in verschiedenen
bereichen mails bekommen wo ich mir
unsicher war auch hier meinen diese
person das ernst oder ist es fake
betrugs denn wie auch immer und oftmals
was hat dann wirklich camper ist wie
irgendwann die idee gekommen er jedoch
auf solche personen ein rede mit denen
machen wieder drüber wird bestimmt
interessant und schützt euch ja auch
dass sie halt nicht drauf reinfällt und
wir starten heute einfach mal mit den
ebay kleinanzeigen betrügern einfach
weil es da so viele von gibt und das
lohnt sich auf jeden fall darüber ein
video zu drehen kurz weg zum bäcker und
ich habe vor vier fünf monaten mal
wieder angefangen bis zum hals über ebay
kleinanzeigen ball kommen und am anfang
bin ich wirklich fast auf sie
hereingefallen
ich habe ihm geschrieben es gibt viele
leute die schreiben nicht dann an die
heißen fett oder irgendwie so
amerikanische englische namen du selbst
war sie eine anzeige da rein und drei
minuten später melden sich schon solche
leute da gibt's wirklich unfassbar viele
frontmann erkennt hier immer an
komischen deutsch macht irgendwie nicht
so sind und die wollen unbedingt mehr
bezahlen als du eigentlich für das
dingen haben willst für dieses video
muss sich natürlich wieder einen neuen
betrüger anlocken weil die anderen nicht
mehr abziehen wollten die werden halt
direkt gesperrt weswegen ich eine kamera
eingestellt hat dabei ging es um diese
kamera hier das ist die sony alpha zv
e10 super ding also würde ich nicht
verkaufen weil ich wusste dass die viele
leute anzieht und auch halt diese
menschen die eigentlich sie nicht
anziehen sollte aber so ein gerät eignet
sich perfekt dafür ist ziemlich teuer
und kann man sie fast so war es dann
auch und ziemlich schnell hat sich der
nie gemeldet ich habe diesen namen noch
nie gehört aber ich dachte mir kommen du
bist halt der erste der schreibt dann
müsst ihr auch mein erstes opfer und
dann nahmen die story so ihren lauf was
ist ihr letzter preis ich will mir ein
ich habe geschrieben 670 euro wäre in
ordnung dann hat er mir gesagt er ist
einfach schon damit er wird noch die
versandkosten tragen natürlich als
käufer eine 700 euro würde mir direkt
überweisen je nach germany aus england
kommt ja da kann man ja sehen wobei ich
nicht ganz weiß ob das stimmt wir werden
später auch mit ihm telefonieren dann
hab ich geschrieben dass wir das gerne
so machen können und er meinte dann
ziemlich schnell ob man das gespräch
nicht auf whatsapp überlagern könnte das
hat den ganz einfachen grund weil ebay
kleinanzeigen oder ebay generell diesen
leuten hinterher ist und die wirklich
sehr schnell gesperrt werden ich muss
auch sagen dass ich ungefähr eine halbe
stunde nach dieser konversation eine
warnung bekommen habe dass ich dem keine
ware schicken soll die wollen halt ganz
klar gegen solche leute vorgehen ist ja
auch selbstverständlich genau und dann
wurde das gespräch auf whatsapp
verlagert ich kann euch alles mal
vorlesen und die rheinbahn wird auf
jeden fall witzig haben bei den chat
verlauf die nummer oben würde ich
trotzdem bald zensieren weil eventuell
gehe ich damit noch zur polizei könnt
ihr mir später sehr gerne in die
kommentare schreiben hallo igel wir
haben uns gerade bei ebay unterhalten
700 euro ja hallo ich weiß bescheid dann
hat er mir direkt seinen namen geschickt
liege preis lydia wo er wohnt explorer
buckingham shire das ist mein name und
meine adresse an dieses versenden werden
ich hab mir dann gedacht ich tue erst
mal so als wäre ich noch so ein bisschen
skeptisch ist ja klar muss ja auch
natürlich wirken wie lange wird es
dauern bis ich das geld bekommen weil
sie im ausland wohnen ich komme aus
deutschland es sich lange ich überweise
die zahlung per sofort sepa echtzeit
überweisung an sie also das klingt ja
sofort 16 das macht meines erachtens gar
keinen sinn diese zusammensetzung der
wörter aber sondern halt möglichst
seriös bringen damit sie ihr geld sofort
erhalten können okay ich gebe dann jetzt
meine kontodaten ja bank nahm account
name e mail adresse und ich stelle ich
die anzeige bei ebay verkauft also sie
kaufen es vorgestellten ja sie können
den artikel jetzt bei ihm entfernt um
andere körperform artikel fernzuhalten
und übrigens wollte ich dann wirklich
was schicken und zwar so elefanten
scheiße es gibt eine seite die heißt
schippe oder so da kann man das halt
weltweit verschicken ich gehe zur bank
und mache die überweisung an dich und
schicke die den zahlungseingang sofort
an die bank okay kann es mir ein foto
von der überweisung schicken damit ich
vertrauen kann wer kein problem kannst
mir jetzt wird dem er fotos von der
kamera schicken ich habe ihnen dann
meine band daten geschickt natürlich
nicht echten das ist auch nicht mein
echter name und noch irgend eine mail
von mir die ich irgendwann mal erstellt
habt weil ich wusste halt ungefährlich
konnte denken wie diese leute dann
vorgehen damit ist wirklich leute gibt
die dann die ware verschicken es
ordentlich und sauber ja alles
ordentlich pipapo ich habe jetzt
mittagspause und er hat mir dann
irgendwann dieses foto hier geschick
kann man sehen die lloyds bank die band
gibt es wirklich das ding ist halt nur
ich würde schon erkennen dass das safe
ist aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen
dass es viele gibt es nicht erkennen ich
weiß nicht wieso was in england aussieht
aber sie steht halt an sich alles
wichtige drauf seine adresse dann steht
da mein name meine iban die natürlich
fällt ist diese ideen gibt es auch gar
nicht wenn man in köln wohnen sondern
halt nur hier wo ich wurde und er
trotzdem die bbc von einer köchin
sparkasse reingeschrieben also das ist
auch schon ein indiz dafür dass das
komplett fake ist weil es gibt dieses
konto dort gar nicht dann kam mir so ein
paar vorgeschriebenen standard ecx also
der arbeitet mit google übersetzer
einfach
dann habe ich ein bisschen nicht kann
würde warum sagst du nicht ich bin
gerade auf einen termin pipapo und dann
kam noch ein paar texte dass ich
unbedingt irgendwas da drauf schreiben
soll damit es nicht beim zoll landet
weil genannten ja nicht mehr in der eu
es ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass das
geld noch nicht angekommen ist da meinte
er ich solle doch mal mein e mail
posteingang und spam ordner überprüfen
habe ich dann gemacht
ach so ich muss euch hier nur kurz die
mail zeigen weil das kann ich nur von
hier das ist ein perfekter übergang die
nbbl geht mich in die nächste runde
checkt das aus
jetzt angekommen hier bei der nbbl und
ich stelle euch jetzt mal mein team vor
wir haben ein extrem sportliches team
wir haben hier erstmal loris server das
geht wird er sehr gute chance ja wir
kein aufgeben und dann haben wir hier
komm ich freue mich dabei zu sein und zu
fahren was geht der ist spontan
eingesprungen alles wird immer wieder
jetzt gegeben hat folger checkt auf
jeden fall super gerne den ersten in der
video beschreibung ab da kommt ihr dann
direkt zu den ganzen ndl turniertagen
können wir sehen wie wir uns geschlagen
haben aber ich bin mir sicher wir wollen
das ding nach hause sind wir jetzt auf
jeden fall gerade in der halle haben wir
den zweiten turniertag gespielt die
ganzen leute also hier am set sind auf
jeden fall wir sind bestimmt 30 35 leute
die hier mitmischen
[Musik]
liegt eigentlich hinter mir ein
sonnenschirm hey leute ich wollte zeigen
hier das kam dann per mail rein von der
lloyds bank natürlich wieder und man
muss wirklich sagen der hat sich schon
mühe gegeben da guckt euch das war ein
sehr sehr krass hier auch mit diesem
transfer
okay wie gesagt die bahn macht gar
keinen sinn und wenn wir uns mal die e
mail anschauen lloyds bank customer
services eskara mail.com
aha also mit mir nicht mein freund das
ganz klar ich werde dich gleich anrufen
dann wird's schon sehr komisch er wollte
nicht dass ich den sendungs belegt von
dieser sendung an seine bank sind damit
diese die überweisung freigeben weil
sowas habe ich noch nie dass sowas macht
auch einfach gar keinen sinn und
schließt weiter darauf hin dass es halt
komplett fake ist zweitens halt wirklich
darum leute das machen wir auf jeden
fall habe ich dann auch gesagt dass ich
jetzt zu posten dann habe ich alles
aufgezeichnet und das könnte jetzt hier
sehr gerne sehen er gibt euch mal sein
profilbild er ist ja auch seinem
vertrauen zu recht wird sich so einen
vertrauenswürdigen kleinen hund wir
rufen jetzt mal an ich bin ein bisschen
nervös ich weiß auch nicht also ich kann
mir schon dass hier nicht drangehen
dran junger
[Musik]
hallo hallo
mit question
to me how many people have you ever die
skate in jamaal hier haben wir die lust
haben die people
ready to the people to 100 people you
know und scans
die kosten für friend of mine who
is working for the police genau
because
it's not me
it's you
know me
because you need money but it's not fair
[Applaus]
so wirklich ein
stop-loss promise to stop it don't stop
it
is ok
[Musik]
seit juni
wir können die friends
also das war jetzt wirklich das letzte
das allerletzte
womit ich gerechnet habe ich bin auf
eure meinung gespannt schreibt sogar
meine kommentare soll ich damit die
polizei gehen oder es lohnt sich
wahrscheinlich nicht aber schreibt
schreien ja leute also das gespräch habe
hat mich wirklich sprachlos gemacht weiß
es ganz genau ob sich das lohnt zur
polizei zu gehen wie gesagt da bin ich
auch auf eure hilfe in den kommentaren
angewiesen ich hoffe nur dass hier das
video natürlich auch verhindert dass
viele von euch darauf reinfallen weil es
gibt ja nur mal so viele leute lieber
ebay kleinanzeigen sachen verkaufen
viele von euch ist die masche bestimmt
auch schon bekannt gewesen vielleicht ja
ich wusste noch nicht so ganz genau wie
das funktioniert und was für leute
dahinter stecken also es hat auf jeden
fall sehr viel spaß gemacht aber jetzt
super g in den kanal wenn ihr mehr
solche videos sehen wollt ich habe
nämlich noch ein paar andere sachen die
in die ähnliche richtung gehen sonst
wird ihnen ja auch super gerne input
geben welchen dingen ich mal auf die
schliche gehen soll oder so vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und daumen nach oben drei
leute